[Music]
tiffany good afternoon how can dr d and
i serve
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
phone call um
first off i wish i had heard of you guys
14 years ago before i went into college
but my husband and i were on the hamster
wheel and
we're just tired of living paycheck to
paycheck and
we are ready to start debt snowball we
wrote down our whole
plan down and we set it on our kitchen
counter so every time we pass it we look
at it and we think about it getting
motivated
um so we are about to attack our
snowball and we're asking for some
advice there's two ways that we can
start it
um one being paying off a credit card
and the other one is towards a student
loan
which i we have together 142 000
in student loan debt um so we're ready
to start this
both the credit card and the student
loan have 3.25
percent um on it but we didn't know
if we paid the credit card at 2800 off
in two months it saves us 85 bucks to
attack another one to start our snowball
but the loan is only 1100 and it would
not make such a dent to pay towards
another
loan for the snowball to start so that
is a part of a group of loans for 442
bucks a month
so i didn't know which way is the better
way to go about it out of debt snowball
is the best
way to go about it and the only way to
go okay um
so i want you might be that from
smallest to largest so walk me through
this process with you what's the
smallest
debt you have right now what's that
total balance
right now it's one of our loans and it's
one thousand
one hundred dollars okay and
what's the other one what's the next one
from there uh
the next one would be one thousand nine
hundred and thirty three dollars
okay and what's the next one from there
um the next one after that would be
going towards your credit cards and that
would be 2200.
2200 all right anything else
yeah i mean we got a whole list of loans
but my husband kept saying that
2800 attacking one credit card at 2800
saving us 85 bucks a month would be the
best option and then hopping over to
another credit card for
5 400 but because
the other loans would be a grand total
of like 400 dollars but it would take us
like
a good amount of time to pay that off to
see that debt
tiffany this isn't this is this is
something for your husband you can
cut this little piece out of youtube or
the podcast and y'all can just
listen to it on loop um this is not a
math
problem this is a psychology problem
this is a spiritual problem
and so everybody has a temptation when
they get into this
thing to try to outsmart the plan or
i got i understand what you're saying so
i get the general gist but
this credit card's got this and we can
win with this here's the deal
both of your plans have landed you where
you're at
yeah and so look in the mirror both of
you hold his hand and i know he loves
you and he's trying his best to like oh
no i'm underwater and so
i'm in a big hole and i got a little
shovel so let's go start digging real
fast
just tell them stop telling me got a
plan yeah anthony o'neil here is going
to walk you through it but this is not a
math problem anymore
this is a psychology problem
he he admires dave because he he sits
there and thinks the same way as you
guys but
um my father-in-law died of a massive
heart attack
two years ago and left us an adherence
and we thought we were doing the right
way and
unfortunately we didn't we have four
little kids
and i'm a teacher that doesn't bring a
lot of money in and then my husband had
a heart attack at 31. oh
man yeah it's hard hard hard luckily
everything
yes so we sit here and i'm listening and
i know what you guys are saying start
with the smallest and i'm like
he sees finance is so much better than i
am but you're exactly right we're here
because this is exactly what we've done
and i brought
the big brunt of student loans because i
listened to someone in my family that
told me college was the only way to go
and that wraps up hey tiffany i want you
to put that down
the i brought this is a we problem yes
and you're you are you carrying more
guilt than him or he's going to be
talking to his buddies being like man i
had a heart attack i had these
medical bills that i wish y'all are it's
a we situation y'all are in this
together
you're going to dig out of this together
and anthony's going to walk you through
the plan because this is what he does
yeah yeah yeah so tiffany it's simple
you know
uh no disrespect to your husband he's
wrong on this one
uh what i want you to do right now just
stick to the debt snowball
this is about catching momentum this is
about seeing debt disappear
this is about you and your family seeing
some small
steps moving forward which is this is
why we call it
baby steps uh because your baby steps
will get larger larger larger larger
larger so so stay the course use the
debt snowball
and you will be all right um man
dr d how are you feeling right now
because right there here you go you have
a wife saying well
this is what my husband wants and then i
think this is what we need to do
and then i heard some other things going
in there that i really couldn't dive
into because that's your expertise with
your phds
your show is really helping
situations like this may not be on the
money side
but on the communication side some of
the deeper issues that are causing
financial things
how do you deal with stuff like this
from a relationship
and just having a clear conversation i i
think just
head on i think i think we're at a place
in our country i think we're a place in
our world and in our relationships that
um we got to stop running we got to stop
hiding gotta stop trying to sugarcoat
conversations
and at the same time never forget that
tiffany's husband he's had a heart
attack he just lost his dad he's got
four little kids he's got a beautiful
lovely wife who works her butt off as a
teacher
he's trying to do the thing that makes
the most sense yeah he's not trying to
be a jerk he's not trying to be
controlling
his heart is in the right place and i
personally dude i've seen the worst of
the worst of people
i've seen some wild situations and i
think most people most of the time are
doing the best they can with the tools
they have in the toolkit
and that's where someone like you that's
where someone like dave
hogan rachel christie ken the whole gang
myself
or we can say hey here's some different
tools you can try out
um you may have never considered this
tool or just to tell somebody hey the
only tool you've got to hammer
stop using it you're just causing chaos
right
and that's where she can sit down with
her husband and say
honey i appreciate you trying to do the
math on this deal
but we're going to stick to dave's plan
it's worked for 30 years work for
millions of people let's just square up
and start from
square one let's pay the small debt off
today